there are circumstances we shouldn't
even socialize with the woman who's not
your wife or not your relative because
we're a [ __ ] that's what we believe we
believe that body cannot be tired he's
all-knowing the most powerful so again
the concept of Jesus died on the cross
me and you will get the regular okay
yeah so I'm coming shriek I ask is
because I'm so intrigued how does it
work for you guys that for example me
personally I got married about two years
ago yeah how does it marriage bosses
were perfect for us it's very strict
that's what for example we can't go on
dates yeah
so is where like meet I want to get to
know somebody I have to go through the
Father how does it work I watch the
documentary on this but how did it is
some complicated them yes obviously
there are certain underlying
circumstances we shouldn't even
socialize with the woman who's not your
wife or not your relative because we're
obviously you have to get married to
marry a stranger and therefore cuts in
the dating process
so normally you would not be allowed to
start get pleasure from looking at a
woman through sorrow but if you're
looking to get married you go on a date
you are supposed to look at this you've
got to make sure your best that's just
it
lots but she has to remain properly
dressed and costly when she's not
covered you can't touch her so there are
certain things which become permitted
when you're genuinely looking to get
married that's quite interested so at
the peak on when it was touching
it's very interesting at the beginning
of the wedding the groom places the veil
on the wine on the bride she has to make
sure that she's the right one cause
she's got the veil on the place we make
sure this is the right one very careful
as a piece of available but they're not
only doesn't touch them also that point
they're not marriages so what if there's
an accident have some other usually you
should try not to talk okay
as they're on their way out of the
ceremony they come out holding so even
when they engage you one actually about
to begin wedding sermon they still don't
touch so in the dating process there are
certainly insist but there's found to
accessable okay so that was very obvious
is the same with our soul when you're
getting to know the other person very
funny I can say before you know enough
to touch her you know I allowed to seem
that you know etc
as well and also another thing is so
when you do the contract how does that
[Laughter]
need something and then you say in the
name of God there is a marriage contract
it's actually written with his written
signed by the villain before the
ceremony
it's the witnesses will go to it
necessarily obvious you have to make
sure they witness beforehand but the
groom we've been through and understand
everything and then during the ceremony
of the bloom at hansard oh that is great
okay all right
and that states obviously various terms
and conditions of marriage rather the
contract doesn't affect the marriage the
marriage is affected with when the man
with the groom gives an item of value
that's usually a ring it can be anything
of value also with one of my really cool
addition position so he says system evil
you will be you'll be married to me with
this ring
in accordance to the law of Moses in
Israel and she she she takes it from
there she acquires the ring and the
witnesses have to watch that process
doesn't create the marriage and there
are other things that's been about month
and then that's two days running we go
straight once that's the first two days
yeah but we can't we can't let our face
by rekhs on your ground so we prefer
clock down in front okay so you cannot
touch the ground or face our patient
close to the ground so you put a paw
down industry with your face on the
clock as we do it once on the first two
days and then on the tenth day is Yom
Kippur where you can straight four times
do you know how we push me don't show
you
that is pretty much right now showerhead
our nose our hands our knees and our
feet have to touch me yeah you like that
but with us we don't actually put our
face on the floor Derek we put a puff
down today we pray three times but on
the festivals people pretended Inc every
day but then on the festivals we have
for services and on Yom Kippur we have
five except on young people they run
into each other swear she praying with a
bang okay so many pillars we face
Jerusalem till you please do too many
people okay we face Mecca but before the
front of Center would face gruesome but
I only got change in this part of the
world if you're facing one city or
facing never from London in London to
face another call
dividend study from here obviously it's
gonna be somewhere in the world so you
know you said yeah yeah so so when you
you know when you clean three times a
day do you have to do some kind of
absolution well the standard thing in
them is washing of the hands that
standard we're its hands full we pray
there are some people who emerge their
entire body in each morning in a special
type of cool that's not obligatory but
some people have that custom obviously
majority terms and then more people the
emotions all discordant make for the
house built and very specific
requirements some people go every
morning some people might go every
Friday preparation for coming Sabbath
okay so you know when you pray if you
don't do this a few times a day beYOU
know we know about them so what do you
do well some of our prayers are ascites
founding someone where it's different
some people sway a bit something like
this be the central power of every
service something as good as the leaders
as soon as this one s a that has to be
said standing together give me to give
up yeah
okay so that's a 908 yeah okay that's
interesting
do you guys drink alcohol
yeah in moderation you shouldn't get a
you shouldn't get to the point where
you're not in control of yourself you
have to drink moderately enough with you
to make sure you don't have anything you
shouldn't do but
yeah last question last question the
long black thing that you guys with all
the other stuff about furry hats yeah
what is that the year do you have to
know that styling certain communities
it's not about them that's the Hasidic
communities they originated from Eastern
Europe it's not standard okay why is the
better offer that's why they call the
generic sound for the actual frogs is
clarity without remedy for these yeah
how ad doesn't mean it's not specific
movement it's just the very very
religious to known as nazaré be and
that's obviously there's there's
different groups and months Rab there
couple different us we all have
different possibilities we've covered
how to shake the hand of God okay all
right I heard this it true that female
animals have to walk on opposites head
or is that is that correct
I heard
[Music]
you have opposite side the streets on
there it's not generally done I know in
in certain isolated places they might
take on you know commune some
communities take on extra children see I
think in Gateshead that's a common
practice but that skates it it's not I
thought well choose duel over the words
okay
certain communities have extra wedding -
Cindy - right yeah I mean again I mean
you talk about you know diverse schools
so obviously some communities are more
religious than others some are stricter
than others some and you know different
customs have evolved so what you'll see
in one community Vanessa 70 standard
having Jews
one last question I promise you that
quite fast the last one the Jewish
ladies why do they have lived with
evening or that marriage ladies should
keep her head covered okay marinate
yeah I already discussed this it's like
a little book yes oh that's a filling
yeah you said that we have to cover
their head yeah but why are they
covering that for example like a cloth
why are they wearing a wig again that's
something that does very you'll find in
many communities through women are
covering my head to the clock they call
it a tip that's like their coffee cover
the head but others others there are
some quite quite commonplace nowadays to
wear the wigs it is you should know it
isn't matter of continuity the some say
it's not really in the spirit of the
laws become an accepted practice the
more religious you tame and that's for
the married woman Tamara so the single
woman don't have this is put on in the
mall